I came to this game sent Dora 88 yeah I
know this reflected but what is it this
is something exotic Africa Middle
America United Arab Emirates hmm okay
well there are almost like like 200
flags so he cannot know the more okay
playing the the Susan variation of the
Sicilian with Bishop c4 black is playing
quick Bishop d7 oopsie 80 mm-hmm I know
Bishop III that's not chief form so not
a good idea okay it's going for a g6
setup at the end
okay
yeah but not a line that I really know
anything about looks fairly comfortable
for black out same
yeah 94 it's probably right and no
bishop maybe no I can just take age 64
of course stupid
okay just centralized yeah that's not a
very very good position really blacks
got the bishop pair no problems so a
very unsuccessful opening Bishop h6 this
rook takes D form yeah I don't want to
play f3 that's really ugly but how do i
how do I get anything going in this
position yeah well that that was really
bad how did I get into this hmm yeah
maybe short cash flow to us really maybe
you really need to play with f3 and and
this this type of stuff with long
castling
yeah here black is just totally fine
I've got a very very easy game my idea
still to try to exchange the dark
squared bishop maybe not f4 to d5 this
okay this is good news night therefore
I'd like to play and I'm sort of winning
a tempo him and maybe prepare night II
to deform need to I know I can take here
play 91 maybe let's do that
channeling c3 Knight f2 trying to
long-term exploit this is the weakened
pawn structure black is still a very
active so he should be fine
yeah I cannot move the night without c3
being played because b2 was hanging so
need to play this somewhat ugly move
at least I believe I need to play it
okay if I go or maybe no reason not to
maybe I get an IT 300 that is that that
was that was probably a mistake I I
don't really believe that he should he
should we can um yeah if I put put so
much pawns on dark squares sorry and now
I have 95 I can you can sacrifice the
exchange now but he he has Bishop h6
possibly okay probably need to do that
rook t5 is probably okay for black
McCain it's not doing that
mmm he's six maybe
hmm let's check this make it more
difficult for him to play six I still
can do that is six I know I don't even
have a three others this is weird what
I'm doing here
and what a strange game earlier yeah I
was I was bad in the opening and any
plate some really weird moves but I
couldn't hide morning couldn't do
anything great just probably a very bad
game by what Jim check no I can actually
take a 6 next move
yeah so you six wasn't a good idea
returning the exchange so like it's a
porn up but this does not mean so much
really
trying to play at for opening up the
position unbelievable that he taking
there's this age for hanging yeah this
this guy is seeing it all 27 though 27
okay so it's not a computer hmm check it
didn't look much like a computer before
but still
check
check-check
black forfeits on time I have 30
hundredths of a second on the clock yeah
this was probably one of the most
rubbish games that I have played yet
what what the heck from this from this
opening to understanding nothing the
whole game yeah this is this kind of
game shows here okay do you need a break
you yeah Black is just in good shape
here no no doubt about it
I hear also have you fire which I didn't
see quite a good okay this this wasn't
bad
so round here should what should be
comfortable if I this is really a
strange move but I think I should have
played it differently this is always
allowing Bishop h6 which I totally
ignored at first yeah it looks very
comfortable but I made now heavily I was
totally off in this game I was thinking
about this movie at the best move and I
thought he can take but I completely
overlooked that even before is also
covered by the Knights I always thought
I can play before no problem of course
your white is just fine so I played this
yeah no no it's just it's just not great
a b3 is just nonsense no black it's
black it's just winning here then he
played this check and gave back the
exchange black is still better yeah this
is the CDC played quickly just spotting
this fe5 Queen h4
and it's it still little bit murky my
man worse
clearly worse but ya got 12 seconds
yeah you just blundered this check and
now it's an easy win with some time on
your head but I have eight seconds check
check yeah I mean I don't know what how
it was chasing or to win here on time
probably you should just give some check
and and I'm overstepping the time yeah
what what a wacky game what the wacky
game okay thanks for watching